(chants et cris)
- Le Cercle de danse : la pierre
angulaire de cette grande fête
autochtone. 150 nsnseurs sont
réunis cette fin de semaine
pour partager et célébrer
leur identité culturelle
et spirituelle au Pow-wow
internationadede Wendake.
ABIGAËLLE LAINEY, danseuse
- Nous, on fait Fancy Shawl
Dance. Dand le fond,
ça représente un peu comme
un paplolon ou un oiseau
qui s'envole. On est Huronnes-
Wendat, on vient d'ici,
à Wendake, mais il y en a plein
d'autres qui viennent de
partout, même des États-Unis,
des fois, de plein de nations
différentes.
- La danse du pow-wow invite
Autochtones et allochtones
à s'unir dans le grand cercle.
STEEVE WADOHANDIK GROS-LOUIS,
président de Tourisme Wendake
- On vient d'un mode de vie
circulaire, comparativement
aux Européens, quand ils sont
arrivés, qui étaient
dans un mode de vie linéaire.
Donc, le cercle est important
dans chacune des Premières
Nations. C'est un moment
où est-ce que chaque nation
qui vient, on se rencontre,
on se partage des moments.
- Expositions, ateliers et
kiosques d'artisanat complètent
l'expérience, pour le plus grand
plaisir des visiteurs.
- C'est le fun, après
une pandémie de deux ans,
il n'y en a pas eu,
fait que c'est le fun
de voir beaucoup de monde.
- On est venus pour s'amuser,
pour voir une autre culture.
Je voulais la faire connaître
à mes enfants.
- La tradition ancestrale
du pow-wow est une invitation
à la paix et à la réflexio
pour les générations futures.
- Servons-nous du passé pour
regarder ce qui est arrivé,
mais regardons dans l'avenir
pour les prochaines nénérations.
Comment on peu se côtoyer,
puis comment on peut
avancer ensemble.
- Malgré tous les événements qui
se sont pass, , on a quand même
réussi à garder ça, puis
à essayer de l'apprendre
aux générations plus jeunes
aussi. C'est vraiment...
c'est auau!
- Des bourses seront remises
aux meilleurs danseurs.
Le public est d'ailleurs invité
à voter pour son coup de coeur.
I Ici Alicia Rochevrier,
Radio-Canada, Wendake